Moi l'accordéoniste
[Musique]
la vie de joie est Belle Au Coin de la
rue la-bas elle a une client qui lui
remplit Son bas quand son boulot
s'acheve elle s'en va son tour chercher
un peu de rêve dans un bal du faubourg
son homme est un artiste c'est un drôle
par petit gars un accordéoniste
qui a dit jouer
Java elle écoute la Java mais elle Ne la
danse pas elle Ne regarde même pas la
Piste et ses yeux amoureux suivez le
jeun nerveux et les doigts secondes de la
reti sal lui rend dans la peau par lab
paire
elle a envie de chanter ses physiques
tout Son rtre est tendu son soufflet
suspendu c'est une Vue de la
[Applaudissements]
musique la fille de la joie est triste Au
Coin de la rue la-bas son accordéoniste
IL est parti soldat quand IL va renaître
de la guerre ils prendront une Maison
elle sera la caissi et lui sera le p
que la vie sera Belle ils seront de vrai
pacha et Tous les soirs pour elle IL
jouera
Java elle écoute la Java qu'elle fonne
tout pas elle revoit son fils
Accord et ses yeux amoureux suivent le
jeune
rêve de l'artiste sal r dans la pe parb
pardon elle a envie de pleurer c'est
physique tout Son idre étendu son
soufflet suspendu c'est une vra de la
[Applaudissements]
musique la fille de joie est
seule Au Coin rue la-bas les
filles qui font la
gueule les hommes n'en veulent pas et
tellement pis si elle crve son homme Ne
reviendra Plus adieu Tous les be
sa vie elle est
foutue pourtant ces jambes
triste je suis Au boui boui ou IL et un
autre
artiste qui joue
tout là
nuit elle écoute
Javale, elle a compris le
javale elle a ferme les yeux
les doigts secs et
nerveux sal lui r dans la peau parlas
parlant etv é physique alors pour
oublier elle s'est mise danser tourner
Au fils du
[Musique]
doit
artez
[Musique]
musique